a lot of people call this the dr. Seuss
house first of all nobody asked dr.
Seuss for permission to do that they
refer to that because of some of the
ideas of dr. Seuss it I think he was a
genius
and I think a lot of good for the world
I try and write poetry and I kind of
think of this as a poem to the sky I am
Philip Paul Widener I'm the owner and
builder Goose Creek Tower but I went to
MIT and I'm kind of a frustrated
architect so I like building I just
designed it out of my head we didn't
have blueprints we drew it out on
cardboard plywood just as we were going
what I'm going to end up doing
eventually put some hooks there and hang
pots and pans off them because this is
the kitchen I started to build a 40 by
40 scribe blog cabin I realized I could
put pillars on top and put another house
on top a house and I just kept going we
got to 185 feet and we stopped because
of 200 feet is federal airspace now I
just have to finish it this is pretty
much the last little stairs there are
multiple levels in there and I've tried
to count them and it's just impossible
it depends how you count stories
I want to be able to see and that's the
reason I went up you can actually see
for at least 300 miles and of course
when the Northern Lights around you can
really see I hope the Goose Creek Tower
will inspire other people want to do
worthwhile things not just in building
but what do they do with their life and
every time I go up there it's a
different experience kind of give you a
sense of the enormity of the universe
you